To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
we'll deliver slashes
and thrusts
on this ballistics dummy.
Collin, you're up first.
You ready?
-Have fun.
-Let's do this.
To help me today,
I'm bringing back
one of Marcaida Kali's
chief instructors.
Please welcome U.S.
Staff Sergeant Chris Manns.
[dramatic rock music plays]
All right, Collin, your
Kabyle flyssa is very sharp.
On the initial thrust, it
penetrated deep and easily
through this whole
ballistics dummy.
The handle is comfortable.
It's easy to slash
in and thrust out.
Overall, it will kill.
Good job.
Thank you, sir.
Daniel, your turn.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[dramatic rock music plays]
[man laughs] Oh man.
All right, Daniel, your weapon
is wicked sharp.
On the initial thrust,
it penetrated deep.
And on the way out,
with your belly being forward,
it lacerates out easily.
Now, because you have such a
very skinny handle right here
and there is no pommel
with a counterweight,
all the weight is in front.
The balance just
makes the blade rotate
with a small handle like this.
But in terms of damage,
it will kill.
-Thank you.
-Good job.
All right, bladesmiths.
Next up is the strength test.
Ben?
Bladesmiths, to test
the strength and durability
of your Kabyle flyssa,
I'll be smashing them
into these
terracotta pots, edge first.
Remember, this test is all about
what the pots do to your blades,
and not what the blades do
to the pots.
Collin, you're up first. Ready?
-Yes, sir.
-All right.
[dramatic music plays]
[dramatic rock music plays]
-Awesome, man.
-[Collin sighs]
Collin, your blade
held up beautifully.
The, uh, edge
looks like it never saw
the terracotta.
-Did a great job. Well done.
-Thank you, sir.
-Daniel, you're up. Ready?
-I'm ready.
[dramatic musical sting]
[dramatic rock music plays]
[tense music plays]
Well, Daniel, your edge held up
pretty well.
If I run my fingers across,
I can feel just a little bit
of a wire edge.
But nothing major.
But my big concern...
This handle.
It's so small that I had
a tough time indexing it.
But it's beautifully carved.
Edge held up beautifully.
-Very well done.
-Thank you, sir.
All right, gentlemen,
you survived our kill test
and our strength test.
Now the sharpness test.
To test the sharpness
of that blade
and to see if it
still has an edge,
I'll be cutting
through these fish.
A clean, sharp blade should
pass right through those fish.
A dull blade is gonna knock
those fish out of the way
or give us a jagged, torn cut.
-Collin, you ready?
-Yes, sir.
-Okay.
- And I'm just thinking,
please just slice
through this thing.
[dramatic music plays]
All right, Collin, right off,
it's definitely a sharp blade.
It cut very nicely.
Your handle is a bit
on the fat side.
But it's definitely a cutter.
Good job.
-Thank you, sir.
-Daniel, are you ready?-
-Yes.
-Okay, great.
I feel that Collin and I
are still neck and neck.
I think that I've got
a good edge on him.
[dramatic music plays]
-[grunts]
-[Daniel] Hm.
All right, Daniel,
this blade is wicked sharp.
And those cuts.
You can see, they just
blew right through the fish.
My problem is,
this is so small,
I had to fight to keep it
in my hand.
These flyssa often have
a very small handle.
But what saves that
is having that pommel
keeping your hand
from coming off
the back of that blade.
It's an amazing cutter.
It's just very difficult
to hold onto.
[Wil] Daniel, Collin,
there can only be
one Forged in Fire champion.
And that champion is...
Collin.
Congratulations,
you are our new
Forged in Fire champion.
Daniel, your sword
didn't make the cut.
Please surrender your blade.
[Daniel] I am disappointed
that I didn't win.
But I'm absolutely proud
of the work I did here.
If anything, I think this fuels
my fire to work harder
and do better.
Collin, congratulations.
You are our new
Forged in Fire champion.
That's a title that comes
with a check for ten grand.
-Good job, buddy.
-[applause]
As far as your animal head
pommel,
I'm gonna go ahead and say
it's probably an underdog.
-[laughter]
-Well, Collin,
please present your weapon
to the judges.
[Collin] Wil Willis out here
telling me I'm a champion?
Can you believe it?!
[grunts gleefully]
Champ! I can't believe it!
Forged in Fire champion
out here.
[groans joyfully]
[dramatic music plays]